vous allez bien bien bien vous allez
bien voir que les mangas en commentaire
il ya quelques semaines je vous parlais
de l'iphone 12 pro dernier iphone
d'apple très très bonne iphone et je
vous avais dit que je vous parlerai un
peu plus tard de l'iphone 12 pronax et
ce jour est arrivé
voyez c'est merveilleux tout vient à
point à qui sait attendre c'est le pari
que la place un jour je les place et 7
jour j ça y est c'est fait alors je vais
pas vous refaire un énième test de
l'iphone 12 pro max puisque l'iphone 12
promax regroupe tout ce qu'on retrouve
dans l'iphone 12 pro mais qui dit max
avec des choses en plus des choses en
mieux donc ici je vais venir vous
détailler ses points de différence je
vais vous expliquer en quoi il consiste
je vous les illustres effet tout vous
montrer tout vous expliquer ça va être
très clair très limpide
du moins je l'espère d'ailleurs si c'est
pas limpide prévu marqués en bas pour
que le fasse taper sur les doigts mais
normalement ça devrait plutôt bien se
passer
on a quelques points de différence il ya
certains paquets sont vraiment
significatif au niveau de la photo on va
donc regarder quelles sont les
différences entre ces deux modèles pour
vous aider à vous positionner entre
l'iphone 12 pro l'iphone 12 pro mac
savoir lequel choisir première
différence avec le gabarit vous vous en
douterez l'iphone 12 prend max est
beaucoup plus grand que l'iphone 12 pro
donc il va falloir qu'ils s'adaptent à
tous les poches à toutes les mains à
toutes les tailles de pantalon de sac
on a également une différence de points
entre les deux modèles iphone 12 pro
fait 187 grammes contre 226 grammes pour
l'iphone 12 pronax moi avec mes mains je
ne fais pas le tour de l'iphone 12
promax avec mes doigts comme satan
disque qu'avec l'iphone 12 pro et bien
voyez c'est beaucoup plus simple
beaucoup plus évident la prise en main
sera bien meilleur la différence vous en
douterez bien évidemment on vient
également de l'écran 6,1 pouces pour
l'iphone 12 pro avec une révolution de
2532 par 1170 sac à 160 pixels par pouce
tandis que sur le modèle max vous avez
un écran de 6,5 pouces une très grosse
diagonale 2778 pas 1284 pixels à 458
pixels par pouce c'est sûr que c'est
très confortable pour venir regarder
votre contenu multimédia on a un plus
grand confort son modèle max que
charlotte modèle il faut donc savoir
vous ce que vous préférez en termes de
format en termes de prise en main en
terme de rangement dans une poche ou un
sac à main la différence est quand même
assez significative d'ailleurs dit moi
vous ce que vous en pensez tout de suite
en bas en commentaire
l'année dernière j'ai utilisé l'iphone
os promax pendant très longtemps pendant
de longs mois et je me suis dit mais je
n'ai jamais réussir à l'habitude un
format aussi grand et lorsque j'ai
l'iphone 12
roh cette année en test je me suis dit
moi il me paraît petit par rapport aux
grands modèles que j'avais l'année
d'avant ce qui est assez dingue c'est
qu'on s'habitue très facilement la seule
chose que j'ai pu remarquer avec mon
modèle max et qui dépassait toujours de
ma poche un petit peu sur le banc des
jeans il dépasse légèrement c'est pour
ça qu'il faut vraiment se poser la
question par rapport à vos usages à vos
méthodes de rangement est ce que vous
avez un sac est ce que vous n'avez pas
de ça qu'est ce que vous mettez dans une
poche
est-ce que vous avez de la place dans
vos poches fournir le loger faut aussi
penser aux côtés un peu pratique et dans
les deux cas ce qu'il faut vous dire
c'est que vous allez vous habituer aux
très grands écrans du max ou au grand
écran du 12 promet là où on a une vraie
différence c'est sur l'appareil photo
ça c'est le blog foot ou votre iphone je
sais je suis très mal vous avez ici
votre capteur grand-angle ici c'est l'
ultra grand-angle tandis qu'ici vous
avez le téléobjectif
dans tous les cas vous avez des capteur
de 12 mégapixels que ce soit sur iphone
12 pro ou l'iphone 12 promax l' ultra
grand-angle c'est exactement le même
les différences opérer ici au niveau du
grand angle et au niveau du téléobjectif
sur l'iphone 12 pro vous avez une taille
de pixel de 1,4 micron m tandis que sur
le modèle max
vous avez des pixels qui sont un peu
plus grands de 1,7 micron m ce qui vous
permettra de capter plus de lumière plus
de détails et d'avoir des photos de
meilleure qualité avec votre objectif
principal mais c'est pas tout puisque
sur le max vous avez également votre
stabilisation optique qui va être
différente sur l'iphone 12 promax vous
avez une stabilisation par déplacement
du capteur c'est une technologie qu'on
retrouve dans les appareils photo reflex
et que apple a réussi à intégrer à son
smartphone on aura donc une meilleure
stabilisation au niveau l'iphone 12
pronax qu'au niveau l'iphone 12 pro mais
déjà la stabilisation de la faune 12 pro
est très bonne et l'autre différence va
se faire au niveau du téléobjectif sur
l'iphone 12 trous en un tel objectif de
12 mégapixels une ouverture de f 2.0
tandis que son iphone 12 promax on a
toujours un tel objectif de 12
mégapixels mais cette fois-ci
l'ouverture est de f 2.2 sur l'iphone 12
pro vous avez un équivalent de 52 mm
tandis que sur l'iphone 12 pronax vous
avez un équivalent de 65 mm ce qui est
fait sur iphone vous propose un zoom
optique x 2 tandis que sur le modèle nax
vous avez un zoom optique x 2.5 vous
allez pouvoir venir chercher des images
beaucoup plus loin avec le modèle nax
qu'avec l'iphone dix pros de la même
manière au niveau du zoom numérique
l'arrivée sur un x 10 au niveau du 12
pro et 1 x 12 au niveau du 12 promax ça
c'est pour la photo mais sur la vidéo
vous avez également une différence
puisque vous arrivez avec un zoom
numérique x 6 sur 12 pro et un zoom
numérique x 7 au niveau du 12 promax ici
je vous prends des photos avec la caméra
grand angle pas de grandes différences
bien évidemment là dessus on va
continuer ensuite avec le téléobjectif
on voit qu'avec effectivement le x 2,5
de l'iphone 12 pro mac c'est bien on se
rapproche davantage ça me paraît assez
normal on retourne sur le grand-angle
pour voir qu'on a un capteur qui est
quand même plus grands eh bien on va
avoir plus de détails et de meilleures
couleurs et bien pour moi c'est pas du
tout flagrant les bleus sont bleus les
verts sont d'air sensiblement de la même
manière le téléobjectif vous le voyez
une fois de plus on vient se rapprocher
davantage mais je reste vraiment dans la
même coloris m apple maîtrise vraiment
bien sa copie d'un côté comme de l'autre
on retourne sur grand angle pour moi
c'est aussi une fois de plus
sensiblement la même chose on vient se
rapprocher avec le téléobjectif la
qualité de l'image est vraiment la même
le grand-angle alors c'est moi qui me
suis un peu dépassé sur l'iphone 12
promax mais sinon le jeune les jeunes de
la même manière les détails sont
exactement les mêmes d'un côté comme de
l'autre même rendu au niveau du grand
angle au téléobjectif
on voit qu'on se rapproche un peu plus
sur la photo de droite avec l'iphone 12
promax mais c'est normal on arrive place
de jaude à clermont-ferrand sensiblement
le même résultat à droite comme à gauche
dites moi si vous voyez une différence
et on se tourne arrive avec le
téléobjectif ont donc on peut se
rapprocher une fois de plus bien plus
avec l'iphone 12 promax qu'avec l'iphone
12 pro on a effectivement vu la
différence au niveau des fautes 11 jours
et on a également une différence au
niveau de la photo nue puisqu'on a un
plus grand capteur au niveau de l'iphone
12 pro match on laisse passer plus de
lumière on aura donc un gain au niveau
des photos nuit c'est son regard
maintenant vous allez voir par moments
la différence allait pas hyper flagrante
ici une différence peut-être parce que
j'ai bougé sur la photo de gauche une
petite différence au niveau des arbres
sinon globalement c'est à peu près la
même chose dans cette photo là je vois
pas vraiment de différence très
honnêtement l'iphone 12 pro est vraiment
très très bon le max de la même manière
on change ensuite à la photo suivante
c'est pareil regardez la luminosité que
ce soit aussi bien au niveau du banc au
niveau du sol au niveau des éclairages
au fond le ciel noir pour moi c'est kif
kif vraiment ici je vois un petit
différend sur l'iphone douce promax
au niveau des reflets en dessous du
traîneau du père noël j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu plus clair un peu plus
de luminosité et la voyait de la même
manière je regarde voilà pas de grosse
différence pour moi c'est quasiment la
même chose entre l'iphone 12 pro et
l'iphone 12 promax pour la photo nuit on
a également une différence au niveau des
batteries entre l'iphone 12 pro life and
death promax puisqu'on a un écran qui
est plus grand il faut une batterie un
peu plus grosse pour avoir une autonomie
qui tient la route ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'en termes d'usagé vous à les emmener
votre iphone 12 prend max
un peu plus loin que l'iphone 12 pro les
deux je les ai tenus entre une journée
et demie à deux jours deux jours il ya
plus grand chose mais j'arrive à la fin
de la deuxième journée
les temps de charge sont sensiblement
les mêmes et vous vous en douterez
également une différence en termes de
tarifs tout est là dessus l'iphone 12
pro commence à 1159 euros pour la
version 128 go de stockage sans
laisserait version 256 go de stockage et
vous coûtera 1200 79 euros et sur la
version 512 ya de stockage 1509 euros si
vous voulez la version mac
il faut rajouter 100 euros à chaque fois
128 go de stockage 1259 euros 256 go de
stockage 1379 ça sent 12 giga de
stockage 1600 ans 9 euros pour 100 euros
d'écart vous allez avoir un smartphone
qui va être plus grands forcément c max
qui viendra obtenir plus de place dans
votre poche mais qui vous accordera
également un plus grand confort sur le
visionnage les performances au niveau de
la photo vont être amélioré l'autonomie
va être un peu meilleures sur l'iphone
12 prom a exclu sur l'iphone 12 pro déjà
avec l'iphone 12 pro vous avez un
excellent photophone apple maîtrise
vraiment mais vraiment très très très
bien sa copie que ce soit pour les
photos que ça pour les vidéos ça marche
super bien
donc si vous voulez un smartphone un peu
plus compact qui marche très bien qui
vous emmènera partout qui est
extrêmement performant les feux de 12
pro est super bien on est ici dans du
très haut de gamme mais si vous voulez
ce qui se fait de mieux en terme de
photos aujourd'hui chez apple
et bien c'est celui là qu'il vous faudra
c'est l'iphone 12 promax vous capterez
un peu plus de lumière vous irez un peu
plus loin avec le téléobjectif si pour
vous la photo quelque chose
d'extrêmement important que vous
travaillez même avec de la photo et vous
voulez pouvoir bosser avec votre
smartphone iphone 12 promax pour 100
euros de plus ça vaut le coup tout le
reste de la configuration c'est
exactement la même chose même processeur
même technologie d'écran même
technologie drame tout est exactement
similaires mises à part ces trois points
vraiment importants
le format la photo et votre batterie a
vous de me dire vous
maintenant ce que vous en pensez en bas
en commentaire qu'à l'iphone est fait
pour vous et scott iphone déjà est fait
pour vous et entre ces deux modèles
lequel vous conviendrait le mieux
l'iphone 12 pro un modèle très haut de
gamme ou alors le mac ce qui se fait de
mieux aujourd'hui chez apple l'iphone 12
points dax mark et moi ça en bas en
commentaire quant à nous on parle très
prochainement d'apple puisque on va se
parler de l'ipad 8 d'ici quelques jours
on va se parler également du macbook pro
13 pouces avec la nouvelle puce m1 mais
également du mac mini
d'ici là je vous envoie beaucoup d'amour
prenez soin de vous et à très vite
[Musique]
souper
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]